we have
restricted uh
immigration and as a result of it you
know we see more wage pressures so this
is Black Rock CEO Larry think and you
guys know Black Rock basically owns
virtually everything in America at this
point they're buying private homes and
they own portions of all our giant
corporations and everything else this
guy has an inordinate amount of power
and how what else are they trying to now
connect this to they they are also
trying to connect wokeness to that
basically America should not have
borders that it would be racist if we
even had borders so here watch watch
this little trick that he does uh he's
talking about immigration and how that
if we don't basically let everyone in
that it's going to cause too much wage
pressure and that would be bad in
essence for guys like him watch we are
going to uh focus on um if the whole uh
the whole idea about restricting
immigration big topic here in Germany
big Topic in the United
States um we are down in the United
States oh close to three million legal
immigrants we've changed the immigration
policy at the same time there's so many
job needs and in the United States we've
had close to a trillion dollars of
fiscal stimulus just beginning its
jcurve and these are huge job creators
and at the same time we have
restricted uh
immigration and as a result of it you
know we see more wage pressure so at
what cost we have in the United States a
very
protracted uh strike between the Auto
Workers and the auto companies it has
been reported that the the union is
asking for a 40%
increase so at what cost what you know
in the long what does that mean for jobs
do more jobs
move okay so I know that that was a
little bit technical but the point is
here he is Larry Fink in Germany
basically saying you guys should have
more immigration and we should have more
immigration in the United States now
first off the G to say it to Germany
Germany is is crumbling because they
allowed in over a million people in the
last what seven years or so right they
have massive stress on all of their
systems they have millions now over a
million people who are not German by any
definition of what a German was right
and you might have problems with some of
the things that Germans have done in the
past uh but that's not what Germans of
of today are right and Germany has a
right to defend its borders the same way
America has a right to defend its
borders and Israel has a right to defend
its borders and Chile has a right to
defend its borders but he's basically
saying hey open up the borders because
otherwise if you don't we'll have too
much wage pressure here and though we're
going to have to pay those freaking Car
Guys those those unionists uh more money
he's doing just fine by the way he's the
guy's got to be worth what he's probably
worth4 billion doar or something insane
anyway it's just it's just
ridiculous